[Music]
hey everybody welcome to Planet Costa
College today I'll be talking about the
launched coaster torque which is a bit
of an unusual coaster since it's only
based on one ride in real life which is
both roller in Six Flags Magic Mountain
and this coaster is made by premiere
rights which is a company that
specializes in launched coasters and
full throttle is also sometimes known as
skyrocket number three and this kind of
gives us a clue as to what kind of
coaster type torque really is seen
skyrocket refers to the cars and trains
that full-throttle uses and there is
also skyrocket too but that's a cloned
coaster type which you see all around
the world which you can't actually make
in game since its launched out of this
station and goes backwards as well and
there is also skyrocket number one in
Kenya would but that uses a slightly
different track which is not available
in games so really the only coaster
which you can perfectly recreate with
this coaster type is full throttle and
that's also what most of its signature
elements come from with that in mind
though I want to say that this is one of
the most popular rides in the game by
far and many coasters that are being
built are of this type since it's so
versatile so in this video I won't be so
much looking into how you can make this
coaster realistically since there's not
much to base that on but instead just
look at some of the more signature
things that you can do with this coaster
and basically how to do with this thing
in game so with that introduction out of
the way let's get into the building
alright so you can find the coaster here
as torque and when we place the station
we want to raise it up a little bit so
it's not entirely on the ground but we
don't have to raise it up very high or
anything and we can actually get into
the launch straight away from the
station that is what all of the
real-life versions of the skyrockets do
and already I do want to say that when
it comes to the acceleration rates of
the launch I would put it up to 9 meters
per second because that isn't even that
fast and should usually get you a pretty
good launch without too long of a
stretch to actually get up to speed
you've got a very small version of this
coaster of course you can always make it
lower but nine meters per second is
already not a very very intense kind of
launch so this should usually just about
do and then the target speed just
depends on how large you want to make
your coaster I can't really say too much
about this exactly because setting your
target speed really just takes some
trial and error just running the coaster
a couple of times and seeing what your
best speed is but that said I think for
me 112 kilometers per hour is going to
be the magical number if you want to get
into the signature elements of this
coaster and I'll explain right now why
basically this coaster comes with an
elements that none of the other courses
in game have which is the towpath loop
and this is the element from a fourth
role and also what makes it such a
special coaster and it's this huge loop
with the track going over it and when
you want to have this elements in your
coaster you really have to get it from
the loop section here and you can't make
it yourself
I've tried to but you can't actually
intersect the track and perfectly
support it just like it's doing over
here so as you can see the bottom and
the top part of the track are both being
used by the coaster here which is really
cool and the only way in which you can
do so is by taking this element now
there is a very easy way to get to the
perfect speed to make that signature
element all you have to do is take the
launch section drag it up to be as long
as you can make it set the acceleration
rate to 9 meters per second and this is
always going to be in meters per second
no matter if you've got miles or
kilometers set and that's basically it
now all you have to do is make sure that
your speed is 112 kilometers per hour or
if you can't exactly do it 113 or
something along those lines should work
as well and place three of these pieces
of track now no matter if you've set
your target speed to 161 you're always
going to have a little bit over 112 km/h
you have got the three maximum length
sections of launch section with nine
meters per second acceleration so now we
can get into the signature elements and
when we test the coaster right here we
should be getting a perfect
to make it through this looping right
here there we go all right now to give
you an idea of what else you can put in
this coaster type I'm just going to make
a very approximate recreation or fourth
row it's by heart though so it's
probably not going to be the greatest
but it should give you a pretty decent
idea of how this thing works before I
get into that though I want to turn up
the banking offsets because this course
it does have a hard line and so we want
to make sure that when we start banking
our track we're going to start banking
around the car itself just to make it a
little bit more smooth so that's what
we're going to do here and I want to
first get into quick few curves and then
I'll be back with you now we're already
at a point here when we're getting our
pretty high in the sky and there's
something I want to very quickly know
it's because you might have noticed that
there are two types of track they both
say basic standard track but they are
very different this one has sort of
simple round spine which is that that
backbone of the coaster track right here
and the second one has a very thick
spine now I haven't been able to find
any sources on this but usually when
coasters have very thick spines like
this it's because they want to use less
supports and this is definitely true in
real life of full throttle as well since
the lower sections with the regular
spine have more supports than the high
up sections with less supports but the
sticker spine so this is what I assume
is the reason and if you really want to
have a realistic coaster I guess you
could go for the second trend a standard
track if you want to have a high up
section with not so many supports to
still make it look like it's actually
sound when it comes to the engineering
but then again I'm not 100% sure on this
it's probably what the reason is but in
any case in most cases just having this
thicker track on part with less supports
or inversions should make your coaster
look a little bit more realistic if you
really want to go for it now full
throttle hits a very interesting and not
so common element here which is a dive
drop which is generally when you're
already up quite high as is the case
here and you're turning around and going
down again into a half loop or a drop in
which you're also inverting and all
we're really going to have to do here is
make sure that we're starting to get
inverting in this curve that we're kind
in here something like that should more
or less do and then we're also dropping
down at this point so let's get to
exactly 180 degrees turn on the angle
snap here and just slowly work out a
half loop going back to the ground and
then we'll get into one very interesting
part of this coaster so our dive drop is
looking pretty smooth and good and I
think it's time to get into one of the
more confusing parts of this coaster and
definitely one that I've seen quite a
few people have some issues with there's
this interesting section called the dual
direction linear synchronous motor and
that might seem like the most ridiculous
name ever but basically what it does is
it's going to stop the train at the end
of the brakes there then it's going to
launch the train backward going up this
element but not too much and after it's
returning from that element going
forwards it's going to launch the train
again so basically it's a backwards
launch and then once it comes back to
this element it's going to be launched
forwards again and again whatever speed
you really want to hit on this thing
just kind of depends on what exactly
you're looking for I believe I'm a
little bit too low for the e coaster to
actually hit the standard full throttle
speed here but that'll be fine I'll just
turn it up a little bit but this again
just takes a bit of trial and error to
get it to actually work but that's the
way it works so usually when you place
these brakes you want to have somewhat
of a high elements behind it that your
coaster can kind of creep up a little
bit as it's going to be launched
backwards to then return and be launched
forwards to finish the rest of the track
ok so again I have a little bit of a
cheat here I usually just get the track
to be as long as you can make it then
put two of these launch sections in and
then will very quickly finish the rest
of the track before I get to the launch
section again so let me quickly make
sure that this is all connected
alright the curve is looking good it's
already launching the coaster forwards
but I'm afraid that's not going to make
too much of a difference here since it
probably doesn't have the speed to get
over that hill oh I guess it almost is
making it but but basically when we go
to the settings here we can see that
there are quite a few things that we can
mess with we've
the reverse launch speed which is the
first thing that we're going to want to
look at this is the speed at which it's
going to launch the cars backwards here
now 76 kilometers in my case is exactly
what I'm looking for since it's just
making its way up this element but not
quite otherwise it might get stuck in
the space between these elements and the
loop at first so we don't quite make it
here so that's pretty good but then we
see that with the forwards boost speed
we're going to have a problem since 112
is not enough to make it over the loop
here so I'll boost it up to about 132
that should make it now we also have
these to hold delay buttons over here
and what these do is they set a sort of
window for how long the coaster cars are
going to have to wait with launching
backwards basically there is always this
little moment as they reach the end of
the launch where they're going to wait
for a second
standstill and then launch backwards now
you notice that was just about one
second and that's because the lengths
that they're going to wait is anywhere
within the range that you set the whole
delay to now I don't want to keep people
waiting too long in the launch but I do
want to kind of have some sort of space
between the minimum and the maximum so
that there's always a different like
time between when you're actually going
to be launched so you never know when
you're going to be launched which is
kind of interesting so I'll just set
this to about two seconds if you really
want to torture your people you could
also have it on thirty seconds but you
know that's that's not really my thing
so now you're probably thinking alright
this is a pretty cool coaster so far
we've got that interesting section where
it's launching backwards and all right
so now you're probably thinking we've
got a pretty cool coaster so far I can't
wait to see what else is going to happen
with this well in real life full
throttle is going to go over this hill
and go into the brakes already on the
hill itself and just end the ride right
there but that seems like an incredibly
boring thing to do so I will show you a
couple more elements which you could
feature on these rides but keep in mind
realistically this is already the end of
four throttle and it's really only in
the interesting top hat and the relaunch
is that it has that it's a cool ride it
is definitely very highly rated right
but it's pretty short as well it doesn't
too many elements so I want to show off
a few more here one other elements which
skyrocket has at Kennywood that is
somewhat worth showing off is the
regular top hats now the regular top hat
is very similar to this except it's
slightly differently shaped since of
course you don't really have to shape it
around a loop so when you're building a
regular top hats you can actually make
it almost vertical so if we take for
instance the top hat at Kennywood it's
kind of shaped like this going pretty
vertical over here and then we're going
to have this moment at the top where it
pops over that small hill probably with
a little bit of airtime I've never been
on that thing so I can't exactly tell
but this is also an interesting element
and if having a loop underneath your top
hats after the launch doesn't really
suit your fancy you can always go for a
top hat like this just a regular old
normal top hat and have that instead of
the giant looping contraption of course
though we do want to make sure that
we're smoothing out this thing quite a
bit and in some spaces like especially
those transitions I really want to hit
the smooth button quite a few times to
make sure that the shaping is good and
that it doesn't become too jagged on the
onride now what you can also do with
these top hats is to install some trim
breaks on the top when it's going very
slowly over there to kind of hold it
down as it's going down just like a dive
coaster to make it a little bit more
scary perhaps by the way I've set these
to a very high deceleration rate because
you really want to catch the coaster and
to a very low target speed because it's
already going down so if you really want
to make sure you can hold down the
coaster with trim breaks you really have
to set the target speed very low and the
deceleration very high now this right
now is pretty awesome
we are losing quite a bit of speed with
that though but I do want to say I'm
just going to make this layout pretty
ridiculous at this point and just show
off some of the stuff that you can do
with these coasters because again I
definitely want to stress that if
anything this planet coaster college
should not be seen as a one on one kind
of tutorial on how to build one of these
simply because they are super versatile
on they're only a few of them in real
life
but more or less focusing on the things
that you can do with these so actually
getting the launch beads right and
working with some of the elements that
we have now one other element that you
could add to one of these rites which
you can find in the non inverted section
is the non inverting loop and I just
wanted to put this here because I think
it's it's a very fun element I normally
don't really pay attention too much to
the in-game inversions because even
though they are very often better than
what you can do yourself and this is in
no means trying to blast everyone here
by saying that nobody can make good
inversions but the in-game inversions
are actually smoother than what is often
possible if you make them by hand so
that's why I would recommend making this
kind of inversion by placing the ingham
on you want to make that a bit smaller
though but I usually just want to
address inversions and elements that you
have to make yourself that the course
that doesn't give you so that's why I
normally do that that's speed by the way
could be a little bit faster but yeah
one of these elements is really
interesting is they're quite common on
the wall they're on every single
skyrocket too so they could very well be
very interesting kind of element for
these coasters as well so we've got some
interesting stuff now these courses can
have pretty much any elements but
there's one element which I want to talk
about because it's a very rare elements
and it's one that the game doesn't
really give you it's the cut back there
is a cut back on the original skyrocket
and this is a super rare element it's
kind of like a corkscrew but instead of
the second part of the corkscrew
twisting again in the same direction you
go in the opposite direction so it's
kind of like a ridiculously over banked
curve and that's also the way that you
make these things you're pretty much
going inverted but once you go upside
down you start reverting into the same
direction again so generally to make
this kind of cut back we just want to
start going up while we're also gonna
start banking a little bit and actually
in this case since I'm going to make it
pretty large you want to make the track
section pretty large as well about three
track sections should work per half part
of the cut back so I'm going to put
another section over here make sure that
we're banking just a little bit more I
might actually make this tiny bit
smaller it's going to be it's going to
be pretty steep but that is what we're
looking for here and we want to make
sure that we are at about 90 degrees
curve at the top so let's see I think
they'll be good
yeah looks like that'll be good I'm
going to start banking or stop the
banking for a little bit there and go
upside down and I think after that we
can already start heading back again and
pretty much do the same thing but in a
mirrored version I want to really try to
make this as symmetrical as I can so
it's usually going to take a little bit
of trial and error and also a bit of
smoothing button to make sure that both
sides of the code back are actually good
but I think this will be yeah there
should be decent it's gonna be a little
bit less steep and then we can end the
curve like that and then the smoothing
tool should take care of the rest
because it's looking very awkwardly
shaped right now but that shouldn't be
too much of an issue
I do wanna make sure though that the
brake run is very slightly angled so I'm
just gonna have a very slight angle to
this end as well and that should be it
let's grab the smooth button now when it
comes to the smoothing this again just
takes a bit of trial and error to get
stuff right but I generally just sort of
alternate between smoothing two track
sections smoothing a selection and
smoothing the entire thing usually what
I do is I want to make sure that both
parts of the inversions are generally
smooth and I usually do that by
selecting one half of the inversion
smoothing it but I also want to make
sure that some transitions are a little
bit extra smooth so this is still
looking a little bit weird going to
smooth that out a bit and I'll do the
same on the other side and as a final
touch to make sure that it's one smooth
fluent motion want to smooth out the
entire inversion and I think that should
be generally good now this is a CRO
Tesla over sized cut back though that's
something I would like to mention most
of them would be well about half this
size perhaps even smaller but this is
really the the basic idea of the
inversion also that's all I've done to
finish the ride is install some brake
runs at the end where you've got some
regular breaks over here
and a few blog breaks over here just to
make sure that we can run two trains on
this thing and that is all we've done to
finish this layout now I want to say
this is definitely a crazy ridiculous
layout and I would not recommend
building something like this this is
just to give you an idea of what kind of
inversions and elements you can build in
these kinds of coasters that aside there
are no real guidelines as to how to
build these things because again there
are barely any of them in real life so I
would just say take this stuff and try
to be as creative as you can with it and
of course have fun while you're building
these things and if you really wanted to
have something realistic or have an
approximate recreation of full throttle
you could have just ended the ride right
here also what I want to very quickly
note is these top hats should definitely
be placed at the beginning of a ride if
anything so they'll be placed after the
launch where you'd be launched going
into the top hats and then waiting for
the first drop that's how I would say it
should generally work they shouldn't be
in the middle of the layout like this
this is just to show you how one of
these things can look anyway that's
enough talk about the coaster let's get
into it all right so we're starting off
from the station straight into the
launch and into the enormous looping
which is actually the second biggest
looping in the world if I'm not mistaken
which does have quite a bit of hang time
but it does that in real life as well
and it's quite nice to have it I haven't
really felt it myself but anyway we're
getting into these curves which are
pretty smooth and long winding into
another section with quite a bit of hang
time and into the pretty rough breaks of
the second launch there isn't really
anything that you can do about these
breaks only the launch speeds you can
actually adjust so there isn't too much
that you can do about the fact that
these breaks to break the coaster down
and down in a pretty rough manner but
overall the launch speeds are really the
most important thing
and we're getting launched at the top
hat and find it pretty good speed and
over-the-top hats with a little bit of
airtime hopefully I'm not sure and into
the second top hats which is really just
there to kind of show you what you can
do with these things but it's still
pretty fun elements down into that
almost vertical drop and over the
non-inverting loop which is one of those
pretty good in-game elements in
definitely something you want to get in
game rather than perhaps making it
yourself unless you really want to get
the shaping that you need and finally
the cut back and our in the breaks which
are also quite rough I would say at the
end you can definitely extend them and
have it break down a little bit slower
but overall I am pretty content with
this even though it's a pretty terrible
layout this is pretty much a lot of the
elements that you can put in these
coasters and way that much of these
elements work anyway that's all I have
in store for today if you guys are still
looking for more inspiration I greatly
recommend checking out the full throttle
POV and checking out the skyrocket POV
as well both very interesting courses to
look at and most of all just have fun
building these coasters because they're
really fun to build super versatile and
can do lots of crazy things thank you
guys for watching I hope you learned
something and I'll see you guys next
time